so let's just jump right in I'm gonna
shut up cuz you're not here to see me
I'm gonna bring out thank you gentlemen
Kevin Feige
welcome to spanking how are you good how
are you feeling hi spike out there to
watch that piece of you guys because it
still blows my mind that guardians of
the galaxy that comes out next Friday
come to the premiere and honestly it is
beyond any kind of nice where I'm not
just saying that cuz you're here but
James has managed to make a visually
stunning film that is hilarious
and action it's topical Sid but it is
our tenth Marvel Studios movie movie the
tenth movie that takes place in our
cinematic universe and I can't believe
in that can't wait for you guys to uh to
see it because it always starts in this
room you know it starts with you guys in
this room up there mm whatever six or
seven it's just it's been amazing and we
put that piece together just for this
room and it's very very cool that's
exciting
particularly this year is we have a
movie called Captain America the Winter
Soldier
gardania's comes out this Friday and I
love the notion that you guys are just
as excited for part 2 or part 3
something that you've already seen
before the next adventure but you're
just as excited for something fresh and
something new with darkness is 2015
where we're doing a very similar thing
we have a movie called Avengers age of
Ultron that comes out you wanna meet
some people of all that I am the
director the first time visiting
comic-con for both of the ant-man
without the introduce you to
the villain of our piece
his name is David Cross we also called
in the Yellow Jacket in the cell Corey
Stoll and if it's some some rumors
recently about who's playing this part
of the zone but now finally conserving
no more rumors Planck the daughter taken
home big night
your 2015 and my cast breed who if you
had any question is whether or not it
might be the right guy for this job what
number comic-con in San Diego
international comic-con this is for you
Peyton Reed this is my 20th anniversary
visit to come 1994 was the first summer
I'm atomic condoms here Jack Kirby
passed away and um I have been every
year since then I think - a couple of
years when I was shooting and what was
the punk band in high school that you
were in for a time in the 80s a punk
band called Jonny Quest and
hey and in addition to being the drummer
of I was in charge of drawing the Flyers
for the shows and now we just show I
think in 1988 and I drew a circle ripoff
of Avengers number one where all the end
members were members of The Avengers of
course ant-man was original Avenger and
I drew myself his hand man and I would
love to live there it is yeah there is
that's it sweet new Jimmy Quest LP final
be a twin snare drum thing when he
wasn't it so long as these are been
working on the film that he brought this
out I'll get you a cassette of I have a
Walkman right here I can totally play
Paul Rudd congratulations you've never a
good company never set up on the stage
before
yeah I'm popping my comic-con cherry
this is it and it is as advertised this
is unbelievable
if you're gonna do it with 7,000 people
to come into the Marvel Universe as you
know what will probably be another like
10 people like they're gonna be you're
gonna be the static for a while they
want that feel like it's so it says mind
bender it's so exciting I'm so honored
to be a part of it it's really thrilling
and and it's kind of tough to wrap my
brain around I mean I've been doing this
as a job for a while but this is a whole
other thing
I'm excited the challenges I'm thrilled
to be working with such great people and
looking forward to see see how it all is
excellent mr. Michael Douglas I never
thought I would say this to you but we
were also popping your cherry as well
cherries
what does the experience like for you to
come in as Hank Pym and what are you
what do you see when your vision for the
character well you know I've always
vicariously looked at Marvel films from
afar with tremendous envy my entire
careers been making out of doing kind of
contemporary movies without any special
effects or anything that so to have the
joy and the love of all these fantastic
tools that sort so well done and the
ant-man story's over there's a wonderful
story and so I mean surrounded with
paints and Paul eventually I'm just
looking forward to a real trip this is
sort of based upon a comic and started
out 1962 Stanley dr. Henry Pym who was a
endocrinologist business system
encourages metal purchase and basically
about the serum to make a person reduce
themselves to the size of an ant but
with the strength of a human being and
then went beyond that more importantly
to learn how to communicate with ants
his answer armies and so this is the
basically the story of a heist his
partner Corey blaze that grow which has
taken the company in a different evil
direction and I have found a mentor in
Paul to take over my position as ant-man
the only trouble is that Paul is in such
great shape such incredible shape
physique the ant-man bodies who just
the earth you the comment girl the front
you have something to say the cherry my
experience so far has been just evading
the press that's been generally been my
experience on MN I've been at the Comic
Cons for two days now answering
questions about MN but officially saying
I'm not in MN so I'm very glad to
announce it I'm super happy to be here
I'm obviously playing Hank pins daughter
hope you say that five times fast
and I can't tell you anything else about
her cuz I don't know I don't have a
script
not yet now you're just the fun where
you can say that you're in it it's
really been an incredible couple of
years for you just in terms of the scale
stuff that you're working on so what is
it
how are you kind of how are you how do
you sleep six months I started learning
meditative breathing practices swear to
God just so I can get some sleep I'm a
mother I'm producing my first children's
book series and starting this month
calm is kind of my world I love I mean
everything it seems like everything I've
ever done on the screen you guys are
right in fray you're in the big loss so
I started here in 2005 and and I was in
college and we were showing a television
show that I wasn't even on air yet and
you were still this was still a packed
auditorium so much love to all of you my
people course also here what can you
tell us about Darren cross for you know
I was Finn's mentee and scientist as
well and I had the company and some very
judgmental people may think that that's
in an evil direction but I think just
taking into the future
what can you tell us anything about
Darren Carl obtain some Pym particles
and and begin to give a man run for his
money and again puts on the suit that is
called the Yellow Jacket Susan is felt
and and causes havoc
so Derek cross actually will be yellow
jacket in the film which is not
previously announced that is it you have
to keep all this stuff in the entire
time so comic-con for you must be like
an incredible release where you can be
open about everything popping cherries
release
you don't have to show you it right
because you have an answer so we start
filming in two weeks you start filming
on the 18th Monday August 18th in
Atlanta come up don't come by so no so
we haven't we haven't started filming
the movie yet but we filmed a little
something to show you guys
thanks that they didn't thanks to fall
thanks to Michael and thanks to some of
the visual effects tests we have in the
works here's a quick look and nn
now that now they obviously go over in
signatures